Herr Mölling sie beschreiben in ihrer
Analyse die ich gerade schon einmal kurz
angerissen habe dass Russland ab dem
Zeitpunkt wo die intensiven Kämpfe in
der Ukraine aufhören 6 bis 10 Jahre
brauchen würde um seine Armee so
aufzustellen dass es eben einen Angriff
auf die NATO wagen könnte wie kommen Sie
zu dieser Analyse na ja wir haben ähm
zwei Faktoren die diese Kriegsgefahr
eigentlich äh sozusagen ausmachen es ist
auf der einen Seite die Motivation was
will russ eigentlich erreichen und da
ist Russland quasi seit Ende des Kalten
Krieges eigentlich sehr klar es gibt
sehr frühe Einlassungen von Putin in
denen er sich traurig zeigt dass man
durch das Ende Sowjetunion viele Russen
jetzt quasi im Ausland leben hat aber
Russland würde nicht dort enden wo die
russischen Grenzen sind das wäre
sozusagen noch ein Teil Russlands dass
das auch zu Taten führt hat man in der
Vergangenheit gesehen dadurch dass viele
Russen die im Ausland gewesen sind Pässe
bekommen haben und man dadurch auch
Gründe geschafft hat zum ist vorläufige
Gründe geschaffen hat vorgebliche Gründe
geschaffen hat um militärische
Interventionen zu rechtfertigen ähm was
jetzt mit dazu kommt zu der Intention
Russlands quasi das alte russische
Imperium wiederherzustellen ist die
steigende Fähigkeit Russlands
industriell nachzuziehen und tatsächlich
Produktionskapazitäten weiter aufzubauen
sie haben völlig Recht zur Zeit steht
das doch keine Bedrohung da weil eben
ein Krieg läuft ind dem dieses her
neuergestellte Material oder auch das
was repariert worden ist quasi
verbraucht wird aber eben mit dem Ende
der Kämpfe in der Ukraine bedeutet das
dass Russland die neue Möglichkeit hat
das was da jetzt produziert wird und in
hohem Maße und zunehmendem Maße
produziert wird dann wieder zu nutzen um
seine eigenen Streitkräfte wieder
aufzubauen bevor wir jetzt gleich weiter
über ihre über das Szenario sprechen und
auch die Aufrüstung Russlands vorab
einmal zum Verständnis was meinen sie in
ihrer Analyse mit ein Ende der
intensiven Kämpfe was ist das wie würden
Sie diesen Zeitpunkt beschreiben ja ja
wir benutzen ganz bewusst dieses Wort
weil wir nicht von Frieden
Waffenstillstand oder sonst etwas
sprechen wollen wie das zustande kommt
und auch wann das ist lassen wir ganz
bewusst offen aber die die
hochintensiven Kämpfe heißt alles das
was wir in den letzten zwei Jahren in
der nicht Regenzeit gesehen haben wo
viel Material wo viel Munition und viele
Menschen im Grunde genommen im Krieg
entweder zerstört oder gefallen sind und
wenn das aufhört wenn also auch der
Verbrauch von
vor Ort in an der Front aufhört oder
auch nicht mehr auf dem Wege zur Front
zerstört wird dann ist eben die die
russische Kriegsproduktion in der Lage
in erheblichen Maße z.B neue Panzer neue
Raketen alles das zu produzieren was sie
jetzt schon kann was aber jetzt zur Zeit
noch zum Einsatz kommt mhm sie haben es
gerade auch schon kurz angerissen wir
haben natürlich in den vergangenen
Wochen auch immer über die erheblichen
russischen Verluste berichtet zum einen
von Soldaten die gestorben sind in hoher
Zahl aber auch von viel Material was
eben zerstört wurde beispielsweise bei
der Schwarzmeerflotte woher will der
Kremmel denn die Ressourcen sowohl die
menschlichen Ressourcen als auch das
Material nehmen um eben so stark dann
wieder zu werden ja also Russland äh ist
auf der einen Seite zurzeit ja noch in
der Lage viel Geld zu generieren aus den
Einnahmen von Öl und Gas auch wenn
Europa das nicht mehr abnimmt der Rest
der Welt nimmt es ab und auch zu höheren
Preisen denn einer der Effekte des
Krieges ist ja dass die Preise
zwischenzeitlich gestiegen waren das
heißt Russland kann seine Einnahmen
weiterhin in einem erträglichen Maße
halten und es ist bereit auf Wohlstand
zu verzichten das ist auch ein
wesentlicher Unterschied zu den
westlichen Gesellschaften Russland muss
keinen sozialen Wohlstand herstellen es
kann viel des Geldes was es einnimmt
tatsächlich in die Kriegswirtschaft
stecken und das ist ein entscheidender
Unterschied zu uns dazu kommt dass
Russland in der Lage ist pro Jahr
zweimal
140.000 Rekruten auszubilden das heißt
also allein in einem Jahr schafft man
ungefähr 280 000 Menschen die an Waffen
ausgebildet sind so vorsichtig muss man
das mal formulieren uns erreichen
natürlich die ganze Zeit auch schon
fragen bei YouTube eine lautet wie kann
man nicht kann man nicht darauf
vertrauen dass wenn sich Russland schon
in der Ukraine schwer tut auch nur eine
Stadt zu erobern warum sollte Russland
dann die gesamte NATO angreifen ja das
ist eine gute und wichtige Frage es geht
glaube ich in der russischen Strategie
nicht darum die NATO quasi territorial
zu schlagen sondern es geht da drum der
NATO einen ersten Verlust zuzufügen und
dann im Grunde genommen darauf zu warten
dass sich die NATO über die Frage
spaltet müssen wir z.B das Baltikum
zurückerobern oder aber können wir was
dann sicherlich passieren wird ein ein
Angebot des Kremmel annehmen vielleicht
eine auf einen Teil des Baltikums zu
verzichten wenn das passieren würde
würde über die politische Debatte die
NATO möglicherweise Auseinanderbrechen
der Russland müsste militärisch nicht
mehr gewinnen sondern die NATO die
zurzeit noch ein Problem militärisch für
Russland darstellt würde quasi zerfallen
und man hätte es mit vielen
Einzelstaaten zu tun das ist das größte
Risiko denn das größte Pfund das die
Nato hat ist die politische Einheit aus
der dann erst eine militärische Stärke
erwächst würde aber bedeuten sie hab
jetzt gerade schon kurz angerissen
möglicherweise ein erstes Ziel von
Russland wäre dann das Baltikum das ist
ein mögliches Szenario ich würde nicht
alles darauf fokussieren aus russ Sicht
macht es Sinn einfach zu gucken wo
Europa am schwächsten ist das wird auch
sicherlich nicht als erstes ein massiv
vorgetragener Angriff mit Panzern sein
sondern wir sehen das jetzt ja gerade
auch an der finnischen Grenze wie quasi
über Instrumente unterhalb des Krieges
versucht wird
m Desinformation zu streuen auf der
einen Seite Unfrieden zu streuen auf der
anderen Seite es werden die Punkte sein
wo man hofft auf der russischen Seite
dass sich der Westen eben nicht einig
ist was jetzt zu tun ist und wenn der
erste Quadratmeter weg ist oder erste
Quadratkilometer ist das verdaubar oder
nicht verdaubar das werden die Fragen
sein und ich glaube dann setzt man auf
die Wackelkandidaten innerhalb der NATO
oder auf die Kandidaten innerhalb der
NATO von den man ausgehen muss dass sie
in Moskau sehr viel näher stehen als sie
das möglicherweise dem Rest Europas tun
uns erreichen bei Youtube auch schon
Fragen die in die Richtung gehen was
kann die NATO was sollte die NATO denn
tun um dieses Kriegsrisiko dann auch ja
zu minimieren sie haben das in ihrer
Analyse auch skizziert in mehreren
Optionen wie die NATO der jetzt dieser
Bedrohung begegnen kann also Herr möling
diese verschiedenen Szenarien die sie
das skziieren die sind jeweils dann auch
mit einem unterschiedlichen Risiko für
Krieg verbunden welches dieser Szenarien
erscheint Ihnen aktuell für ja am am
wahrscheinlichsten ja meine Befürchtung
ist dass ähm die großen wichtigen
Staaten in Europa die vor allening in
Westeuropa liegen zur Zeit die schnellen
und hohen Investitionen scheuen das Ziel
einer solchen hohen Investition ist ja
vor allen Dingen das Signal Richtung
Moskau dass man sich
keine nicht der Idee hingeben sollte
dass die NATO unvorbereitet wäre darum
geht es geht ja nicht dabei darum einen
einen Krieg vorzubereiten irgendeiner
Art und Weise sondern es geht immer noch
darum Moskau davon zu überzeugen dass es
zu keinem Zeitpunkt eine militärische
Option gibt um seine politischen Ziele
umzusetzen
das ist im Grunde genommen der der
wesentliche Startpunkt ähm die Gefahr
ist aber tatsächlich dass
Europa weil es finanziell zur Zeit so
unter
unter großen Lasten leidet und auf der
anderen Seite äh die Kriegsgefahr
möglicherweise oder der die die
Dringlichkeit etwas zu tun wieder
absinkt durch die weiteren Krisen die um
uns herum passieren dass das in den
Hintergrund tritt und man dann im Grunde
genommen zu spät ist und das bedeutet
dass man schlecht vorbereitet ist
dadurch die kriegswahrscheinlichkeit
eben steigt weil man ein Fenster
aufmacht für Moskau wo Moskau denken
könnte ah es könnte sich lohnen lass es
uns doch einfach mal versuchen
das wäre im Grunde das Schlimmste und
dann würdeel selst eine späte
Nachrüstung dazu führen dass man zwar
seine Armee noch gut ausrüsten kann aber
das abschreckungssignal das er dazu
führen soll dass der andere zu dem
Schluss kommt dass es keine gute Idee
ist mich anzugreifen das fehlt dann in
diesem Moment und wir steigern im Grunde
genommen durch eine zu späte Investition
eigentlich eher die Kriegsgefahr in
Europa sie sagten jetzt gerade schlecht
vorbereitet sozusagen von Seiten der
NATO was meinen Sie damit
genau na schlecht vorbereitet heißt dass
ich das was an an kriegsniveau an an
kriegsfähigkeit oder
Verteidigungsfähigkeit notwendig ist um
Russland von einem Angriff abzuhalten
oder wenn er stattfindet im Grunde an
der natogrenze bereit stoppen zu können
dass das zur Zeit nicht gegeben ist
darüber sind sich eigentlich alle
nataaten einig gleichzeitig sind sich
auch alle natostaaten einig dass
Russland die größte Bedrohung zur Zeit
ist also der Text den sie eben
vorgetragen haben ganz am Anfang ist
nicht quasi aus unserem Papier sondern
ein Zitat auf das sich alle natostaaten
geeinigt haben das heißt das ist im
Grunde genommen erstmal die Ambition
dass man das verhindern will dafür fehlt
es aber zurzeit in der Tat an an
Material aber auch an Soldaten in Europa
an Kommandos an an Stäben und an vielen
Kleinigkeiten Europa ist also insgesamt
nur auf einem sehr niedrigen Niveau
derzeit verteidigungsfähig und das
Wichtige dabei ist halt dass Russland
jetzt schon produziert
m das heißt also dass es uns quasi einen
Schritt voraus ist und diesen Schritt
müssen wir aufholen es geht nicht da
aber um das was wir derzeit machen
weiterzumachen sondern tatsächlich ja
einen Zahn zuzulegen und das sehr
schnell zu machen um tatsächlich ein
klares Signal Richtung Moskau zu senden
mhm uns fragt Neo bei Youtube wie
realistisch sehen Sie denn die Gefahr
eines gegenseitigen Wettrüstens wenn ich
sie jetzt richtig verstanden habe dann
ist in diesem wetrennen wenn man es mal
so benennen will Russland schon zwei
drei Schritte voraus richtig ja das kann
man so sagen ob es ein Wettrüsten ist
das ist immer eine sehr schwieriger
Begriff klar ist aber das Niveau das
dass man erreichen will innerhalb der
NATO wird vorgegeben durch das was
Russland wahrscheinlich in den nächsten
Jahren erreichen wird ähm und eben auch
nicht mehr also es geht nicht darum
einen Angriff gegen Russland
vorzubereiten sondern das was man meint
was Russland erreichen kann innerhalb
der nächsten 6ch Jahre dass man das im
Grunde in der Lage ist zu kontern und
damit keine militärische Option für
Moskau als plausibel als gut erscheinen
zu lassen darum geht's das jetzt in
Panzern Flugzeugen auszudrücken wäre ein
bisschen sehr simpel das zu machen es
hat auch viel damit zu tun wo das
Material ist ob man Zeit braucht um es
heranzuführen ob es schon Vorort
stationiert ist alles das hat Einfluss
da drauf wie verteidigungsfähig man
tatsächlich ist also Amin Körper sagt er
hat Putin heute erlebt gewissermaßen wie
lange nicht mehr keine verbalen Attacken
gegen den Westen er inszeniert sich als
der der für Frieden sorgt in ihrer
Analyse beschreiben sie aber sozusagen
das Gefahrenpotenzial was von von
Russland und auch von Putin und vom
Kremel ausgeht wie passt das beides für
Sie zusammen ich glaube es passt sehr
gut zusammen wir
sehen ja nicht nur in den letzten zwei
oder 10 Jahren seit 2014 sondern im
Grunde genommen
seit Anfang der 2000er Jahre dass Moskau
sehr einen sehr klaren Plan hat wo es
hin möchte und wohin es zurück möchte
und dass es das nicht nur offen sagt
sondern dass es dem auch Taten folgen
lässt der Ukraine Krieg oder der Krieg
in der Ukraine durch Russland hat ja
nicht erst 2022 sondern schon 2014
begonnen äh auch wenn Russland keine
Erfolge wirklich verzeichnen konnte hat
es diesen Krieg eskaliert zu dem größten
Krieg den wir zurzeit in Europa haben
seit 75 Jahren das ist schon
beeindruckend also dazu glauben dass
Moskau nach Alternativen nicht
militärischen Wegen sucht um seine Ziele
durchzusetzen ähm das ist äm etwas ä wie
soll man sagen etwas blauäugig glaube
ich in dem Zusammenhang mhm es gibt eine
Frage bei Youtube von Silvia Greiner die
dann eher noch mal auf diplomatische
Lösung abzieht abzielt und zwar fragt
sie Herr Mölling trauert Putin der
zerbrochenen Sowjetunion hinterher gibt
es überhaupt noch Chancen für Gespräche
mit ihm wie schätzen Sie das ein
ähm also nach all dem was man lesen kann
in den Quellen
ist es tatsächlich etwas
wo es einen großen Verlust oder das
Gefühl des Verlustes alter Stärke gibt
ähm das ist auch in vielen Schriften die
Putin selber verfasst hat oder die Leute
um ihn drumhum verfasst haben immer
wieder so ausgewälzt worden dass es im
Grunde darum geht Russland zu
alterstärke zurückzubringen ähm und äh
dass einem dafür im grundommen jedes
Mittel recht ist in dem Zusammenhang
wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen
sozusagen von einem russischen Angriff
auf die NATO dann wäre im Bündnisfall
natürlich auch Deutschland und die
Bundeswehr gefragt wie ist die
Bundeswehr denn iher Einschätzung nach
jetzt gerade überhaupt für ein solches
Szenario aufgestellt
ähm ja die Bundeswehr ist dafür zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt sehr schlecht
aufgestellt
das was eigentlich zugesagt worden ist
also die die drei Divisionen die ab 2025
zulaufen sollten da sieht zurzeit so aus
als ob die nicht zumindest nicht in in
dem in der Kampffähigkeit bereitgestellt
werden können wie das eigentlich
versprochen worden ist zumindest die
erste nicht die zweite möglicherweise
auch nicht sodass insgesamt Deutschland
seinen Verpflichtungen die es zugesagt
hat und worauf die Alliierten Vertrauen
tatsächlich nicht nachkommt man muss
aber auch sagen dazu gehört eben nicht
nur div Visionen zu haben sondern
Deutschland bezeichnet sich selber
wieder als drehscheiber also als
logistischen Knotenpunkt unsere
Infrastruktur ist aber nicht in der Lage
zu derzeitigen Zeitpunkt größere
Truppenbewegungen tatsächlich sicher
durchzuführen also alles das was von
Westen nach Osten in einem Fall durch
Deutschland durch müsste da ist ein
großes Fragezeichen ob unsere Brücken
unsere Straßen Haupt in der Lage werden
das zu tragen und das dritte ganz weg
von den Streitkräften ich glaube das ist
ganz wichtig die Frage ist würde die
Bevölkerung tatsächlich eine
Verteidigung des natogebietes mittragen
und all die Änderungen die notwendig
sind um diese Verteidigung überhaupt
erst möglich zu machen das hat auch was
damit zu tun wie wir in Zukunft die
Möglichkeiten schaffen in diesem Land
miteinander zu kommunizieren also hat
was mit digitaler Infrastruktur zu tun
es hat aber auch was damit zu tun wie
wir in Zukunft es möglich machen durch
dass durch unsere Dörfer und Städte
tatsächlich Militärtransporte
durchfahren können alles das sind Dinge
die unseren Alltag verändern wden und
die Frage sind wir bereit unseren Alltag
dafür zu verändern weil wir sagen ja
okay das ist es uns wert auch wenn wir
nicht sicher sein können dass Russland
die NATO angreift das kann sich niemand
es gibt keine Glaskugel in der man das
jetzt voraussehen könnte auch m Moskau
glaube ich hat diesen Plan zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt nicht aber es erarbeitet sich
die Optionen und zu sagen wir wollen
dass wir im grundom in diesem Fall in
der Lage sind als als Deutschland
tatsächlich dem entgegenzutreten mit
unseren Alliierten da sind wir glaube
ich in dem Bewusstsein nicht das ist das
was der Verteidigungsminister
Mentalitätswechsel etwas abstrakt
angesprochen hat es geht da drum dass
die Möglichkeit eines Konflikt ist und
dass wir Teil dessen sein könnten nicht
nur Zuschauer sondern tatsächlich
aktiver Teil dessen sein könnten dass
das zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht Teil
unseres alltäglichen Denkens ist und
auch unseres Handelns nicht ist und dass
wir es wieder ins Auge fassen müssen
weil sonst steht die Bundeswehr aber
auch die Bundesregierung quasi auf
verlorenen Posten denn ein eineen
Verteidigungskrieg durchzuhalten ohne
die Unterstützung der Bevölkerung ist
tatsächlich nicht möglich denke ich mhm
sie sagte Bundesverteidigungsminister
Pistorius hat davon gesprochen man
müsste kriegstüchtig werden wenn ich ihn
jetzt so zuhöre zum einen sozusagen das
offenbar fehlende Bewusstsein in der
Bevölkerung zum anderen aber die jetzt
nicht gut genug aufgestellte
Bundeswehr kann Deutschland sozusagen in
in diesem ganzen Prozess sich eben
stabil stark gegenüber Russland zu
präsentieren ja offenbar keine tragende
Rolle spielen oder zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt nicht das ist ja auch der
Grund warum wir dieses Papier
geschrieben haben um klar zu sagen es
gibt eine Deadline bis dann müssen wir
im grundenommen fertig sein noch können
wir das schaffen aber dafür muss die
Politik eben die die Weichen stellen da
haben wir zurzeit äh im Gegensatz zu
Putin so hart muss man sagen viele Worte
aber die Taten sind noch viel zu gering
als dass wir ähm da tatsächlich unserer
Verantwortung nachkommen würden die wir
bewusst übernommen haben wir wollen die
modernste schlagfräigste Armee in Europa
haben davon sind wir weit entfernt ähm
und es bleibt uns eben nicht mehr
wahnsinnig viel Zeit um das zu werden
und um damit eben einen Krieg in Europa
zu verhindern weil man klar machen kann
es lohnt sich nicht ähm zu überlegen ob
man gegen die NATO tatsächlich ein
Angriffskrieg starten sollte aus
russischer Sicht Herr Mölling ich würde
es gerne noch einmal verstehen weil sie
sind ja durchaus sie haben ja durchaus
eine eine Stimme mit Gewicht sage ich
jetzt mal im politischen Berlin was sie
da formulieren ist ja einigermaßen
dringender dringlicher Appell haben Sie
das Gefühl sie werden nicht gehört oder
woran hängt es gerade nein wir haben uns
zur Aufgabe gemacht in dem Papier die
unterschiedlichen Informationen die
eigentlich zu die eigentlich da waren
einmal zusammenzutragen und miteinander
zu verbinden das sehen Sie auch
tatsächlich sehr schön in den
Zeichnungen die wir gemacht haben
um damit klar zumachen
eine Verteidigungspolitik die sich
ständig nur in die Zukunft verschiebt
und alles das was gemacht werden muss in
eine in eine nicht bezifferbare Zukunft
verschieb gibt die spielt tatsächlich
mit dem mit dem Risiko dass der Krieg
tatsächlich steigt ob wir gehört werden
m wissen wir nicht wir geben zumindest
die Möglichkeit dieses Papier ist ja
öffentlich
darüber ab jetzt zu diskutieren das war
unserer unser Impuls hier mit die
Möglichkeit zu zu haben darüber zu
sprechen was muss passieren und eben
nicht nur bei den Streitkräften sondern
auch mit Blick auf eine verläliche
Rüstungsindustrie eine
rüstungsindustrielle Landschaft die
diese Armee unterstützen kann aber auch
im im viel größeren Kontext ähm eine
Diskussion in Deutschland darüber zu
haben was braucht es denn wie
wahrscheinlich ist der Krieg wir haben
viele Menschen die davor Sorge haben
wobei ich den Eindruck habe ähm dass die
Bevölkerung an vielen Punkten
weitergedacht hat und viel klarer sieht
auf die Risiken als das teilweise im
politischen Berlin der Fall ist mhm ein
Kommentar der jetzt noch bei Youtube
erreicht hat da geht's dann auch ein
bisschen in die Richtung ja um sozusagen
Verbündete von Russland ich vermute eine
langfristige Aufteilung der Welt in
bricks und NATO ist das auch eine
Befürchtung die sie teilen würden mit
dem User
ähm die Befürchtung kann man haben das
Gute ist und das ist glaube ich ganz
wichtig dabei ist noch können wir das
beeinflussen wir haben viel zu offene
Position wo man denkt wir sind
Beobachter wir sitzen quasi vor der
Mattscheibe und betrachten das alles nur
nein wir haben noch die Möglichkeit
zwischen den Optionen zu wählen ob wir
sozusagen auf Sicherheit spielen wollen
oder ob wir auf Risiko spielen wollen
und das was wir dem Papier machen ist
wir zeigen auch welche Optionen ähm
dafür da sind
ähm sehr einfach skizziert erstmal ähm
aber im Grunde genommen gibt es das
klare Signal noch haben wir die
Möglichkeit auf Sicherheit zu spielen
wenn wir die Zeit verstreichen lassen
und Denken na wir wollen der Bevölkerung
nicht zu viel zumuten dann spielen wir
tatsächlich auf Risiko mhm ein weiterer
Kommentar lautet auch bei Youtube von
Mario sec die NATO ist militärisch auf
einem anderen Stern sie ist dermaßen
stark über legen dass es schon
lächerlich wirkt dass Russland ernsthaft
ein natoland angreifen könnte die NATO
ist eine andere Liga wenn man ihn jetzt
die ja vergangenen 20 Minuten zugehört
hat dann würden sie diese Einschätzung
ja sicher nicht teilen oder
na ich glaube man muss vor allen Dingen
das ist das Wichtige und das ist auch
das schwere teilweise in die Zukunft
schauen ohne zu glauben dass das was man
sieht die Realität sein wird in der
Zukunft wir sprechen über das Risiko das
steigt
weil wir sehen ja dass die NATO Staaten
selber zurzeit sagen wir haben nicht
genug Munition ja kein Staat innerhalb
der NATO ist möglicherweise derzeit
darauf vorbereitet
tatsächlich einen längeren Krieg zu
führen eine der wichtigsten Lektionen
aus dem russischen Angriffskrieg ist
dass die industrielle Unterstützung für
Streitkräfte ein ganz zentraler Faktor
ist das können zurzeit die europäischen
Streitkräfte meiner Meinung nach
tatsächlich in dem Maße nicht leisten
wie es wie es notwendig wäre die
industrielle Unterstützung ist nicht
ausreichend wir haben hochqualitative
Waffensysteme wir haben aber zu wenig
davon das ist im Grunde das Problem das
heißt Quantität ist eine eigene Qualität
und auch das hat dieser Krieg gezeigt
das heißt wenn man gar nicht mal ein
hochintensiven hochtechnisierten Krieg
führt sondern einfach nur mit viel Masse
operiert das ist das was Russland
demonstriert hat dann kann man einen
Teilerfolg haben es geht nicht darum
dass die NATO quasi militärisch besiegt
wird sondern die NATO das es ist
sozusagen eine der Optionen die auch
innerhalb der NATO immer wieder als
Risiko gesehen wird die NATO kann sich
selber besiegen indem sie sich politisch
zerlegt dafür kann Russland aber die
Lunte an die NATO legen indem es gelingt
tatsächlich nur einen kleinen Teil von
natogebiet einzunehmen und dann ein
Angebot an die NATO zu machen zu sagen
wir machen einen
Waffenstillstand das kleine Stück von XY
das könnte doch aufgeben das ist doch
kein Problem das würde aber bedeuten
wenn die NATO sich darauf einließe oder
einige nataaten sich darauf einließen
dass es unterschiedliche natoitglieder
geben würde diejenigen die Sicherheit
genießen und diejenigen die keine
Sicherheit genießen die wir im Grunde
genommen Russland zum Fras vorw en mhm
sie haben jetzt schon gesagt sie sehen
sozusagen gegenwärtig in Deutschland
nicht die Führungsrolle wer ist denn da
möglicherweise jetzt ihrer Analyse nach
in charge zum einen wenn es darum geht
sozusagen die die NATO zusammenzuhalten
aber auch Impulse zu setzen für eine
gemeinsame für eine starke militärische
NATO ja Deutschland ist in charge
Deutschland hat sich selber in die
Verantwortung gesetzt durch die Aussagen
des Bundeskanzlers durch die Aussagen
des Verteidigungsministers
das können wir jetzt nicht einfach zur
Seite schieben nach dem MTO sorry wir
sind noch nicht soweit wir sind noch in
der Lage soweit zu sein und die
Versprechen die wir sowohl unseren
Menschen hier in Deutschland gemacht
haben als auch gegenüber den Verbündeten
gemacht haben diese Versprechen
einzuhalten das ist nicht einfach aber
ähm ich wüsste nicht warum man davon
jetzt ablassen sollte m und damit die
Politik aus ihrer Verantwortung
entlassen sollte